ketchup so American it's basically the
red in red white and blue right and that
red clearly is from the tomatoes the
ketchup is made from but that wasn't
always the case the first recorded
recipe for ketchup comes from China and
for more than a thousand years
it wasn't even made with tomatoes it was
made with fish guts fish intestines
bladder and stomach all mixed together
with salt then sealed and heated in the
hot Summer Sun for twenty days that was
the original ketchup a fermented fish
paste that dates back to sixth century
China it was popular throughout
Southeast Asia and British and Dutch
settlers who arrived in the 1600s loved
the stuff over time they brought ketchup
home to Europe and added their own
modifications including beer mushrooms
walnuts oysters strawberries and peaches
by the mid 1700s English ketchup was a
mainstay on British dinner tables and as
colonists went west
it soon made its way across the pond
that's where Tomatoes come in they're
native to the Americas and it's rumoured
Europeans once believed they were
poisonous but poisonous they were not in
1812 a Philadelphia horticulturalist and
scientist by the name of James Meese
introduced tomatoes into the mix he
published a tomato ketchup recipe that
was the beginning of a new Crimson era
from there many different iterations
were concocted and by the end of the
18th century the New York Tribune called
tomato ketchup America's national
condiment that was on every table in the
land which brings us back to this tomato
ketchup is here to stay and I for one
don't miss the fish guts